[Music]
a popular university has issued an
apology for sending asian students death
threats oh crazy
[ __ ] the university did
harvard sent death threats to the
chinese student association that's
[ __ ] really funny we just start off
and say they didn't mean it yeah it was
a mistake you did it or the other
students on campus the university how
the [ __ ] did the college do it i will
[ __ ] kill you don't even give us more
news yet let's keep on batching off
[ __ ] this morning you're going is it
a school with a lot of asians like uci
or university of kentucky i think it's
like harvard harvard an ivy league
school is it is it like a pretty
high rate let's ask 21 questions i had
never heard of it
oh that's not california when i hear of
it i'm like okay that makes sense is the
location in a place where you would
think this would go down absolutely not
really
canada so it's in a progressive oh oh
it's canada
whoa
that's a big school because you know
canada is so nice oh toronto deathless
to asians i get it really yeah exactly
toronto there's a lot of asians so they
had intended
okay and that's important intended to
celebrate the lunar new year by
distributing free red packets or hong
bao
oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah
so what do they do instead just for the
people watching who are maybe not asian
in a couple of years you could [ __ ] that
up they're typically envelopes filled
with money that are given out for
celebrations such as birthdays and
weddings inside the packets given to
students however were pieces of paper
called hell money
hell money death notes is a fake
currency meant for the dead yeah oh i
used to love those because i felt like i
was super rich you mean the gold ones
that you burn at funerals yeah there's
like an emperor on there yeah yeah this
is what they look like
so what happened they put it in there
and gave it to all the yeah they passed
it out it's like a cultural enrichment
like yay yeah cool we're all we're all
in it together who was the person with
this bright idea like they have so many
chinese people
they couldn't get a chinese consultant
for this [ __ ] yeah you guys gotta get
chinese consultants yo uh yeah so so let
me just read this anthony lee
he knows all bro go to hell [ __ ]
where's our uh
let me show you guys
last year okay so so uh the statement
reads yesterday
in celebrating the year of the tiger
grad house staff place red envelopes for
students and residents to take in the
common area however in the red envelopes
there are a few gong fight choices
hell money uh for the money for the
deceased which are tinges
burnt for the dead
uh usually used during the chinese
festival
uh please lunar earlier
and it's polite to give crisp money
which anthony has given to me it's real
money two dollars two dollar two dollars
hotel money no death threats here well
yeah toronto hire me so they're saying i
believe i do not need to further explain
why receiving a red envelope with hell
money is upsetting if not traumatizing
for asian students who are celebrating
the new year yes traumatizing though
it's traumatic joe come on dude if you
open up on your life
ah you think oh there is a whole
generation of [ __ ] these days you
know you don't think this is you don't
think this is like helpful from like a
like their heart's in a good place right
it doesn't matter the heart's a good
place i think this is cool that's why i
got judged by intent i thought they said
something really [ __ ] up like i
thought they were just like get your
[ __ ] ass back to china or something
like that or i'll kill ya yeah you would
think that's what it is and they're like
my bad i'm like oh we just intended to
help you get home i thought they sent
like stuffed corona viruses to all the
[ __ ] chinese students or something
see that's a that's creative yeah
because imagine if if you got an
envelope and then you pulled out a
[ __ ] card and had a bat on it and it
said see you later alligator or some
[ __ ] like see you later alligator as
usual though uh bart comes up with
something not even a racist writer's
room could come home
what are you talking about maybe because
i am racist
what do you think of that [ __ ] that's it
it makes it much better because bart is
actually chinese there you go mm-hmm uh
so yeah the the uh that's a large-scale
oopsie for the school but it is pretty
funny though at least they didn't mean
how can you [ __ ] up that bad boy or did
they they're an educational system like
there's levels to that you know what i
mean
can we see who the i just i just i just
want to see who was responsible what do
you think he looks like how do you think
it's like a master lube or something
like that okay but turn your chair 360
come back as that guy all right there
you go i'll surprise you
i'm a white grandma
i think you're gonna identify yourself
that way okay that's how they talk i
don't know the toronto accent it's like
a vowel pokemon says its own name so the
best the best part of this is uh that
some people are saying oh come on it was
completely intentional there's no way
they didn't see it on the bills before
they put them inside the envelopes and
they should never been distributed to
begin with i hope they find those
responsible i don't like that dude like
how do you how can you assume like
intent well that's what this person's oh
come on you know they were trying to
[ __ ] with me you know they were
you know they were like you don't know
give people a chance to explain their
[ __ ] i mean it's not the first thing
that that people get wrong like asian
culture wise that [ __ ] happens every
[ __ ] day on the news all i will say
is this makes it
much easier for people to be like yeah i
really want to get involved in this
because they're like oh [ __ ] i'm
stepping into a [ __ ] minefield i
gotta understand how the university
might make a mistake with the intention
to put like money in there but obviously
they're like we're not trying to give
actual money to people so we want to
give this almost like that the symbolism
right the intention of it so like oh
well this is this is currency that's not
the same as real currency of j you know
chinese culture they couldn't get movie
more i went to a chinese super market or
something if someone could prove that
there was some intent behind it then i'd
be like okay but just to assume that
they're gonna go through that elaborate
thing it's like the guy who's in charge
of it it's like you check his facebook
group he's got some [ __ ] neo-nazi
stuff and if only it was that easy i
wish well here's the thing as usual i'll
be the only person who's offended
because i am white so i'm offended you
guys thank you thanks for that yeah you
guys are going to be [ __ ] i'm
offended though don't be our savior dude
how dare you literally he's not our
savior he's actually
our critic thank you i could use some
save us man
[Laughter]
steve is our white shield so like what
would be more racist if there was uh
like broken toys or some [ __ ] if the guy
leaving it if the guy leaving it at the
door runs away
like that oh yeah yeah
that's pretty much it or they
specifically meant uh
actual death threats but then they gave
it to even the wrong race
i mean it's like to me it's like the
equivalent you know you're not supposed
to have your chopsticks in the food yeah
it's like so few people know that so few
people exactly uh
everyone knows that that's wrong
do they get do they give this to all
these students or just exclusively the
asians yeah because
or like the chinese student association
that's what confuses me yeah like then
how is it not in charge like how are
asians not
[ __ ] funny
it doesn't say but the schools also
apologize too so i i think that shows
that they're like oh [ __ ] my bad that's
not what we're trying to do like is this
worthy of a story
you know yeah in this day and age yeah
yeah i guess so because we gotta spread
[ __ ] bitch-ass people are these days
it's like a michael scott moment oh yeah
yeah yeah exactly
that's exactly yeah yeah exactly yeah
yeah cause like i i feel like uh it's a
little tone-deaf but he means well aka
if the university of toronto was the
office it would be okay right but it's
the university of toronto
obviously you know the the university
was like hey let's tell these asian kids
to go to
you hell do it what's not racist enough
to get everybody use their culture as
the vehicle to send that message i just
had to set it i just dipped the sugar
for red bull ready to do some [ __ ]
you know i'm feeling very micro
aggressive today
let me let me [ __ ] throw some [ __ ] in
their face you know how can we progress
white supremacy this morning
how are we progressing how do we subtly
tell them to go back to asia
i don't know yeah so a lot of people in
the comments as usual youtube comments
are well uh this is comic sans.com
comments uh very classic of course this
is all very intentional
you know they're so hurt they're gonna
cry now
people are getting blown up it's making
sense no evidence nothing just oh of
course it's intentional how many times
have you guys seriously had an example
though like just growing up of like
people
trying to make a connection but they
have no [ __ ] clue about anything
asian almost exclusive right so so then
you can see like can't you see it from a
mile away where they're like every
conversation they'll just try to relate
it to chinese food or something
and then that's to me that's like bridge
building it's like he's trying they're
trying they're trying right they're not
sitting there like they're just [ __ ] i
don't know what to do you know what i
love orange chicken maybe i could talk
about orange chicken yeah you know like
yeah you're not dealing with a scholar
who understands the world you're dealing
with the [ __ ] [ __ ] university of
toronto if anything scholar does make
sense right now i'm not even talking
about i'm not even talking about toronto
i'm talking about in life where you've
run into these examples right of like
people that are just trying to connect
with you i used to get really mad about
that like when i was younger but then i
realized it's just them trying to like
you said trying to build a connection
did they fumble it a little bit yeah but
you know i think their heart's in a good
place i think you [ __ ] it up by going
actually you racist son of a [ __ ] you
know they're racist
and relating it back to the universe of
toronto i don't think the dean's
handling i don't think the chancellor or
anybody i think it's they probably just
have some sort of like like student
organization probably handling it and of
course you're not having a scholarly
dude doing it i think there's a dumbass
michael scott that's in charge of doing
some like president of the stupid event
yeah [ __ ]
yeah well you guys it's a white guy as
the president of the chinese closer club
there
you guys will be happy to know in
closing that the university was able to
fix this because they actually um showed
that they have a couple of asian friends
see yeah i took pictures with two asian
guys they tweeted that they have some
asian friends and so everyone's like oh
okay gave him the green light because on
the flip side if you had a chinese guy
right straight from china that was the
dean and he's trying to like show
italian kids some love he might send
everyone a pizza or something
and i don't know that might be viewed as
racist somehow yeah it probably would
yeah especially with little sizers
but he's trying i mean hey hey man try
you know for like eight like the
italians say
pizza pizza
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you